je souhaite sûrement quel changement de
décor l'aide parce que la ville c'est
pas bon pour nous ici ce serait la
chambre du pp la maison elle est en
vente depuis un moment pourquoi il
n'intéressait personne il y a eu un
accident aulas on veut pas savoir moi
oui
il ya eu un suicide
un double homicide
on laisse tomber je suppose a maintenant
j'ai toujours aimé les maisons hantées
on l'achète
presque trop beau pour être vrai
[Musique]
arrive pas ouvrir ses portes
je pensais qu'ils avaient justifient
ils étaient ne suis vraiment désolé j'ai
pas voulu vous effrayer je présume que
vous n'êtes pas des gens d'ici
qui est qui et vous disant que vous avez
plus proche d'un voisin
qu'est ce qui est arrivé au petit camion
je sais pas pourquoi des choses
disparaissent vous avez cessé la
thérapie suite au déménagement est
ménagé deux verges et les choses
[Musique]
j'ai remarqué que les fenêtres de la
chambre des têtes loué
pour pas que les gens s'en rendent
compte que ce qui faisait de
lui ressembler
et parlez moi du garçon qu'il n'a pas
été tués ils habitent la maison juste à
côté
c'est cette maison j'ai pas l'impression
d'être ceux ci
[Applaudissements]
l'armoire de bois et une raison pour
laquelle on les a mis cela
[Musique]